[Applause]
[Music]
how are you so good to see you good to
see you in real life I know I know not
no longer over Zoom we all get to wear
pants again so you love food but wait
there's still one thing that even you
don't like right there are several
there's several what's something like I
hate brussels sprouts really no matter
how you make them so those bright red
maraschino cherries give me the heebie
JoJo's for real really
really uh green bell pepper so I can tie
the stem oh I love you you know just see
if you're a good kisser like from Junior
High yeah yeah wow I really feel like my
resume is what no my grandma could so it
explains why I have so many aunts and
uncles yeah
Grandma yeah seriously well the little
makeup my grandma anymore the cherries
and what else I would say you know those
little chunks of ham like in the Denver
omelette oh like that like cartilaginous
texture I don't like that it's like
rubbery yes yes yes little like grisly
texture that's not polite and green bell
pepper like like royal green bell pepper
I love bell pepper but you know the
thing is it's like an autumn leaf it's
they're the exact same pepper but when
the chlorophyll breaks down like an
autumn leaf they become red and orange
and yellow yeah but when they're green
It's actually an immature pepper and
like in very select cases but usually
it's just not my thing oh my God I love
that's like the one thing I grow in my
garden that I always have oh really well
green yellow red all pepper I love bell
peppers so good
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]